[Music]
[Applause]
OneWayfunction Minimum
Sanction of Classical Cryptography asyou
Thisisverybron
Factor
casemption
evening
TX
Changesposibo
without sunction
classicalcaseWe
needtionwitch
Strongerthe
daysConstant
round statistical high ring commitment
isnowfromfunction
constract interactiveONE
thatevenMulti
computationstion
MANIAthatMaybe
Stronger
youcancractMulti
party compilation EvenPublicCscription Center
Application called black hole
Physics
Output quantum style
oninputeN bit string  Series
Security Challenger
Shoe Thing of Bit B
Ifbease=
theCHALLENGERN
Bit String OK
uniformlyatland
T copy Background
All Challengers
=
CHALLENGER
T copy Haar Random States Isuzu
Just Complete Random Pure States thisStayissendto Advanced efi Thisisjustsome9PTR
thatoutputsM9Bit
State
oninputathingofit Must
Satisfied Indies
this
the
efi efiis
justicalVersionthis
efi is
Introducing
longagobygoldray
AndHisSHOTthis
Classical version Just
toclassical
distribution
that is Competential independent
defined this
classical version
efiHISShoutthatthis
classicals=And
classical case justthis
=
Introduoused3
Now I
explain Why
interesting
S
WORLDmicroclipd
wherefunctiondonot
exispremitive
igood
Maybemicrosethe
worldmini so
ifyouifyourstion
and
Theyacty usefory
constractive
PRSG
Applications
Bo
Explain Construction of Primitives
Microcrypt
isConstruction
OfficialBinning
Statistically binning
comidnet
andreit
TheCenter
prsgAlcohol
Background
onlyonthis
justWoman
WeCanconstract
compitering&
Statistic Binding Cot
Wecanchangethis
flaverbyusingDays
And
interactive digital
signature andtoEXtoexperiend thisconslection firstIjustreview
Classical Construction Digital Signature Clar Earthsport Signature Effects
justfunctionand
SecretKeysRandom Rich Novel Bitstream Public
Key
Thatisused
forication
and message0
isjustthisISO signature
4message1 Justthis
A's
verifier computer
computer and Fonthis
signiteand check weather
this
security just come
fromtheonewaynesof
thisfunction
TheBirthdaycanget
this
function
Hi-chan's computer display
imagefromthis
Wecanusethis
Idea
andfunction
withonewith
generatorpublick
Island
becauseoftheone
waynessofthisoneway
sted
genersarycanfind
correct systemBad
thisconstructions
OnlyTimesequech
andclassicalcaseyou
cancontractmany
TIME
security menu  Time Secure is
Front One Time Secure is
just this for this
now can
stays and classical case called
Sign Public Key
&JustYoucancract
manytime Secure
Simulation PKS
thistheopenproble
theConstructionofa
pkefrom Microcrypt
Primitive
Constructor Almost All Primitive from this microcript premitivefrom
this
microcriptpremitive
itisOpenweatherWe
canweekenthisACTION
to Weeker
premities
and
inthis
Construction
Public Keys Just Quantums
WecanHisomenice
trapped and thatwayWEED
onlyfaction
andusual
isnotauthenticked
channelyWEED
Signature
fromweeker
WhatistheCOMME
Version
Iintroduce OneWays
generatorswithjust
somequantumtime
algress
verylosemVersion later
stelweekooddefine
somemore
Another
Variant
like
thisjustcontumber
thatoutputand
Securities given disk
Phantom and FINALthis
classicalIt
Random Classical
Case U23gbs
Inwhatthe Classical
Complex  And Sanction and
Necessary4GSnot
=NPisness
anything
exceptfor
thewithoutbyshow
that peacenot=
Badforothercaseisi
don't HowtoshowSee
Yourwithout
andoneisShadows
justo Techniqueware That's Giventy
Copies of Canton Sam
trvis Zenyuzuki Classic
&getthisclassical
data
Youcandoyousomevely
longclassical
conptation It
's a computer called
Projection of Given
Shadow and graph susceptible to set for
just
evenif
this
technictoshowthat
prsgbrokenbqpez=
funtamsTRS
ord
Animation
Navy Soinsted Bull Classical Complex
History Wecanconster
contumcomplexy Class
Hardly PNP Space bqp&9
and
qmware
Class later classical INTHE
SENSE
andoutputer
complexity
crasterquantom
complexityClass
outputer
studysomecomplexity
forgeneratingCandy
complexityfor
distening
bymoresuitable
Y
Ifirst
manationthefunction
theminimamasunction
toWEEKS
ApplicationsWhatisthe
minimamasunction
[Applause]